when some violent  psychopath murders people a violent  psychopath who's able to get a weapon so  easily 18 year old with two  ar-15s if you want to stop  violent crime  the proposals the democrats have none of  them would have stopped this why does  this only happen in your country i  really think that's what many people  around the world just  they cannot fathom why only in america  why is this american exceptionalism so  awful  you know i'm sorry you think american  exceptionalism is awful i think this  aspect i think this aspect of it  you get your political agenda no it's us  god love you senator it's not i just  want to understand why you do not think  that guns are the problem  but you can't answer that you can't  answer that can you say you can't answer  that why is this why is it that people  come from all over the world to america  because it's the freest most prosperous  safest country  and maybe the most